ما تخافيش بتلم علينا بتهجم علينا ما
تخافيش بتلم علينا يا جماعه
[موسيقى]
جزيره الخفافيش هي ليها اسم ثاني هي اسمها
جزيره نابليون لان هي على شكل القبعه
بتاعه نابليون لكن هي الناس المحليين
بيطلقوا عليها الخفافيش لان يسكنها
الخفافيش بطريقه كبيره جدا
رعب رعب حرفيا
الجزيره نفسها بالنسبه للخفافيش هجوم
الخفافيش على الناس دي حاجه قليله جدا لكن
العدد كبير جدا جدا من الخفافيش في اي حد
بيجيله او بيجيله زعر من الخفافيش ما
يفضلش ان هو يزور المكان لانه ممكن فعلا
يتضر الضرر ممكن ما يجيش من الخفاش نفسه
ممكن يجي من ان هو يقع من على الجبل لان
هي الجزيره كلها شبه الجبل احنا قعدنا
نتصلك الجزيره لغايه لما وصلنا للقمه
اثناء التسلق ده لو حد خاف من الخفافيش
ممكن يقع يتكسر ممكن يقع يحصل له حاجه
اصابات جامده كمان
دايما بحبه وانا مسافر اتعامل اكتر مع
السكان المحليين واسالهم اسئله عن السلامه
لكن دايما مش في كل مكان الناس بتديكي
تعليمات السلامه لازم احنا من نفسنا نخلي
بالنا ونسال ايه هي تعليمات السلامه ايه
المخاطر اللي ممكن نواجهها نلبس حذاء عامل
ازاي فبداوا يوجهونا ان احنا نخلي نخلينا
كلنا قريبين من بعض ان احنا واحنا بنتصلق
نمشي في مكان معين نخلي بالنا ما حدش
يتزحلق نلبس
الهايك نخلي بالنا من الخفافيش لان ممكن
يهجم عليك فممكن تتزحلق تقع يحصل لك حاجه
وهكذا فدي من تعليمات السلامه اللي خدناها
واهتمينا بها واحنا طالعين لقمه الجزيره
كان في جزء بقى ده التحدي وده اللي كان
اصعب حاجه بصراحه اللي هو الجزء بتاع
الممر تحت الشجر وكان كله خفافيش صوت
الخفافيش كان مرعب كنا عايزين نخرج من
المكان باسرع وقت ممكن عشان نوصل للناحيه
الثانيه من الممر دون ونشوف الجزيره ونشوف
الطبيعه هناك عامله ازاي والفيو عامل ازاي
الباقي بقى التسلق لغايه القمه بتاعت
الجزيره نفسها كان المكان يعني سليبري
شويه بيزحلق شويه فكان لازم نخلي بالنا
واحنا طالعين فدي كانت الصعبتين اللي
موجودين على جزيره الخفافيش او جزيره
نابليون
في تجارب كده وانت مسافر بتفرق معك كتير
جدا بتحس ان خلاص انا الرحله كده خدت منها
اللي انا عايزه تجربه كانت جميله جدا
وانصح اي حد يروح رواندا لازم يزور مجموعه
الجزر دي